(Wind howling)
Milchick:
Okay, go ahead and have a seat.
(Click)
♪♪
(Clearing throat)
My name is Mark S.
I'm Helly R.
My name is Irving B.
My name is Dylan G.
And I have of my own free
accord
elected to undergo the
procedure
known as severance.
Awesome.
♪♪
Mark S.
I give consent for the Lumon
corporation
Irving B:
and it's a good corporation.
Helly R:
To sever my memories between my
work life...
♪♪
Mark S:
Oh!
...and my personal life.
(Laughing)
Dylan G:
I acknowledge that once the
procedure is complete
Irving B:
I will be unable to access my
personal memories
Mark S:
whilst on Lumon's severed floor.
♪♪
Mark S:
Nor will I retain work memories
Dylan G:
when I return home at the end of
the day.
♪♪
Helly R:
I am aware that this
alteration is comprehensive and irreversible.
♪♪
All:
I make these statements freely.
♪♪
Milchick:
Okay, that's a wrap.
♪♪
(Door opening)
Um, open or closed?
♪♪
Both.